a familiar question rocks the marvel
cinematic universe what if in episode 1
of the new animated series the question
gets supplied to agent carter
specifically what if peggy carter stayed
in the room when steve rogers became
captain america
agent carter wouldn't you be more
comfortable in the booth
no i'd prefer to stay
the answer it seems is chaos drawing
hydra's attack on the super soldier
program by undercover members of the
state department peggy's slightly
altered proximity to the super soldier
serum changes the whole game steve is
shot before he can receive the life
altering injections and lies bleeding on
the floor while the capable carter drops
the saboteur and tells steve to stay put
short on time and bereft of other
options carter climbs into the
transformation chamber and gets pumped
full of the serum herself she emerges
transformed a towering goliath of proper
british strength she receives a shield
all her own adorned with the union jack
and almost immediately starts beating
her alternate universe american
counterpart at the winning world war ii
game nabbing the tesseract from arnhem
zola without much mess or fuss
steve rehabilitates and with the help of
howard stark's engineering prowess
starts piloting a suit of hydra stomper
armor powered by the allies recently
acquired tesseract newly outfitted in a
playtime and mech suit powered by an
infinity stone and an insatiable
patriotic go-getter attitude steve
rogers enters the fray and joins captain
carter on the battlefield let's hear it
for captain carter
but the fascist smashing good times
can't last forever and captain carter
finds herself at her lowest point right
around the end of the story's second act
during operation where eagles dare steve
is apparently killed in action thanks to
a stash of dynamite hidden on a hydra
train peggy interrogates and imprisoned
arnim zola learning that the red skirt
is planning to bust out an
interdimensional champion at castle
creek in the black forest accompanied by
the howling commandos howard stark and
bucky barnes cap invades the castle
inside of castle creek our heroes
discovered that the red skull has
captured rogers the hydra stomparama and
the tesseract that was inside it he
opens a portal summon engel of crafty
and horror from beyond the veil of
existence to bring about hydra's reign
of terror the terrible bc has more than
a little in common with the classic
marvel monster shumar gorath but as has
often been said he who lives by the
unspeakable alien abomination must also
die by the unspeakable alien abomination
and so the red skull gets smeared into a
red paste hoisted by his own extra
dimensional tentacle afterwards stark
does like a good sci-fi super scientist
is supposed to do and hits some buttons
frantically trying to reverse the
polarity hard enough to make the rapidly
expanding squid bits go back to where
they came from but to no avail steve
rogers now rescued and back in his jury
rigged patchjob powered armor runs out
of juice before he can make much of an
impact the only solution to the tentacle
problem is for captain carter to
personally shove the eldritch horror
back from whence it came she disappears
into the unknown promising steve a dance
on her way out everything fades to black
almost 70 years later carter returns
flanked by cuts of jumbo squid out of a
cosmic cube induced portal at what looks
like the joint energy mission facility
in the mojave desert from 2012's
avengers a super soldier plugged from
history stands ripe with promise of
becoming the hero of a new era it's all
terribly familiar
so what do we learn here today
a lot is implied by the universe
presented in the first episode of what
if first off howard stark was capable of
coming up with an iron man suit capable
of harnessing the power of the tesseract
potentially shifting the course of human
civilization but the really intriguing
question that the episode leaves open is
what would a world without peggy carter
look like we know that agent carter was
instrumental in the creation of shield
during the 20th century of the mcu
proper an organization that itself
became an annoying incubation chamber
for hydra the dark energy labs seen at
the end of the episode looks well less
manned than the one from avengers maybe
it's a coincidence or maybe hydra got
more of a foothold without peggy around
to keep an eye on things we don't see
anything about the world outside the lab
circa 2012 but it's hard to imagine that
things went better without the
supervision of one of the allied forces
most legendary agents even with bucky
and steve set up to stand in for her
without bucky to use as their vibranium
armed super soldier hydra wouldn't have
had their go-to agent available to kill
howard and maria stark on december 16
1991
thanks you almost ripped my arm off
without as far as absence tony might not
have had any reason to rise to the
occasion and learn how to take the wheel
of his old man's company what's worse
with iron man adjacent technology
entering into play some six decades
early a whole new set of potential
travesties would be lined up assuming
that the u.s government retained the
rights to the invention the course of
manned warfare on earth would have
drastically changed and an international
race to create powered suits would have
likely kicked off during the cold war
opening the door to mid-20th century
versions of the crimson dynamo titanium
man and iron manga then again maybe
howard stark held on to the technology
for himself and went into business
selling iron man suits powered by
tesseract energy with the cube no longer
destined to sit in mothballs for decades
in the wake of his up close
comprehension of its potential maybe
howard used the tesseract and his
physics defying abilities to finally
realize that new elements that it had
his eyes on but couldn't create thanks
to the limitations of his day dozens of
conflicts across u.s history would
suddenly be shifted thanks to the
presence of legions of iron men perhaps
howard refuses to relinquish the
tesseract to project pegasus halting the
creation of captain marvel and dooming
the earth upon the arrival of thanos the
implications are countless or maybe
we're just really overthinking a cartoon
and everything's more or less the same
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you